I think prospects for continued growth
and China are very good for the next
decade or so you know all the
fundamentals that have led China to grow
well or remain in place for another
decade or so after that things start to
change because of China's one-child
policy the labor force is actually going
to start to shrink as early as twenty
twenty so I think once you get past
twenty twenty it's going to be very hard
for China to grow rapidly because when
your labor force is declining it's very
hard to keep up high growth you know but
2020 is 13 years away I think prospects
for growth are good to me the biggest
single issue or challenge that China
faces is natural resource scarcity and
environmental degradation so while
China's growing well there are a lot of
environmental problems some of those are
getting worse the people are very
concerned about this you know so the
government is started doing attitude
surveys or household surveys to get
people's input into what they think the
government should be doing when they did
this in Beijing the two biggest issues
on people's mind where air pollution and
traffic you know so I think there's a
lot of pressure on Chinese government at
central and local level to try to
improve environmental conditions to try
to improve the quality of life and it's
a big challenge to keep up that that
eight to ten percent growth and also
improve environment at the same time so
I really do see that as the key
challenge that the country faces in the
next 15 years or so
you